Speaker 1: All right.
Very big news yesterday.
And we have to give praise to Congresswoman
Cory Bush for really pushing for this.
The I would call this a progressive victory
of sorts, even though it may be struck down
by the Supreme Court relatively quickly.
The CDC has extended the eviction moratorium.
We talked about this last week.
We talked about this a bunch of times because
it's a really important issue.
The CDC has issued a new eviction ban based
on the pandemic effective through October
3rd.
The former moratorium expired last month.
As we covered, there were 11 million Americans
behind on rent.
As the Delta variant suggests, this will be
targeted at areas of the country experiencing
high levels of infection from coronavirus.
It will last 60 days until October 3rd, and
the protection could cover around 90 percent
of renters.
Now, this may be struck down.
And I think that, you know, I'm giving you
both sides of it.
This is really a progressive victory.
And Cory, Bush deserves a lot of credit.
She was instrumental in pushing this to happen.
At the same time, there is a big Supreme Court
threat that this will not hold the there is
a Politico article which calls it a potential
clash with the Supreme Court.
And what's at issue here is whether the CDC
really has the authority to do this.
And it may well be the answer that the Supreme
Court comes up with.
Maybe no.
Joe Biden yesterday said he went to constitutional
scholars to find out about the CDC's legal
authority and what they do that is most likely
to pass muster constitutionally.
And Biden said the bulk of the scholarship
suggested this would not pass muster in the
courts.
But there were some scholars that said it
could.
This targeted moratorium comes after the White
House insisted for days that the CDC doesn't
have the authority to act and that Congress
must pass an extension.
The House has left for a multi week recess
after failing to pass an extension with Pelosi
and other top Democrats furious at the White
House for putting this at their feet.
So bottom line, this may not hold.
It appears as though the opinion of the Supreme
Court is that the CDC cannot do an eviction
moratorium, that it must come from Congress
and Congress is out of session.
Let's hope that's not the way it goes down.
But I think we have to be prepared for the
reality that it may.
Of course, this is an absolutely crucial thing
to do.
There are people who, even in normal non pandemic
situations, can't afford an unexpected 400
dollar expense.
Something like half the country can't.
So if you have two, three, four or five even
more months of rent stacking up and all of
a sudden the protection against getting evicted
goes away, you were at real risk of getting
evicted.
Now, just one other thing.
I don't believe that the nearly the 11 million
or even eight or nine million would actually
get evicted.
There are things taking place at the state
level.
There are other programs that are available
to some of these people.
So the number really at risk of getting evicted
like in the next month was nowhere near the
11 million.
It doesn't change the importance and significance
of doing this.
And now we have to see if it will hold up
in court.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that Monday, August 16th, is the
16th anniversary of the show.
And we'll be doing a big membership special,
if you'd like to be notified about it.
With instructions on how to take advantage,
get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.